the anti-vaccine movement continues to
thrive in part due to online
misinformation groups for some
conspiracy theories are a way of life
but as people go deeper down the rabbit
hole are they joining a cult
we asked the sociologists to walk us
through the similarities and the
differences between these online
communities and cults people do have
this idea that all cults are religious
which absolutely isn't true there's
every kind of cult therapy cult ufo cult
eastern cults new age cults you name it
and of course there are political cults
political cults can thrive just like any
other cult they can be from the left or
the right i myself was in a a left-wing
cult
back in the 70s and 80s people are
forming online communities and finding
the same sense of belonging and purpose
as they would have in a physical group
they do have
the same kind of closed mindset that we
see in cult members
it's important to realize that it has
nothing to do with religion it has to do
with the behaviors of the group
according to dr lalich's framework cults
share four behaviors or characteristics
a transcendent belief system systems of
control systems of influence and a
charismatic leader
the transcendent belief system is the
overarching ideology gives you the
answers to the past the present and
future so it's a new way for you to
understand the world and your role in
the world and it's exclusive in that
you're led to believe that it is the
only way to think it is the only true
belief system and it's inclusive in that
when you are part of that you feel like
you're a member of the elite you're
special and those other people who
aren't part of it well there's just
something wrong with them a scroll
through the messaging app telegram shows
that online groups like saab mc generate
misinformation they also forbid their
members from being vaccinated the q anon
movement especially in its heyday
the anti-vaxxer movement they basically
generate that same kind of transcendent
belief system and the anti-vaxxer
movement in its anti-science attitudes
is saving us from this thing that's
going to get injected into us and it's
going to put a chip in us q anon was
saving us from the satanists and the
evil doers i'm sure people remember
pizzagate and the idea that there are
pedophiles running the government it got
decent honest people who cared about
child abuse who cared about sex
trafficking latching on to this as
though this were the answer sometimes
these groups will have rallies and
demonstrations where they'll go out and
be
you know absolutely fervid just roaring
and raging and and having the kind of
exuberance uh for their own beliefs um
that that can seem quite frightening to
those of us who are watching from the
outside what is the plan to save the
world from
the
evils that are
out there one of the things you might
notice when we look at cults is that
people are sometimes doing things that
seem unbelievable to those of us on the
outside why would someone go rob a bank
who never would have done something like
that before and this is part of that
re-socialization process where
your sense of morality that you brought
into the group with you is being altered
so that you're taking on the morality or
the immorality of the cult leader and
and you'll end up doing things that in
any other context you wouldn't have done
[Applause]
the kind of
us versus them mentality that's taken
over has really generated this this
outward violence that we hadn't seen
before
so systems of control are the sort of
overt obvious rules and regulations of
the
group that you must follow in some
groups you may be told where to live or
who to live with in some groups you may
be told to divorce your spouse who
doesn't want to be part of the group
they may be telling you what to wear
what to eat it can be any of those kinds
of things that is part of stripping away
your individuality is there a parallel
in online political groups these online
communities do have their own systems of
control where people are expected to
speak a certain way behave a certain way
they'll wear t-shirts that are
expressing their belief or their love
for a certain idea or there's obviously
the kind of paraphernalia that is
familiar from those of us who've studied
cults those kinds of slogans are very
useful you know lock her up
so systems of influence
are the more
subtle manipulations of your emotions
you know guilt shame fear love and one
big part of the systems of influence is
the peer pressure the chanting of the
slogans at the rallies is one of the
systems of influence
because it's what we call a high arousal
technique it basically gets the believer
or the follower pumped up right and when
you get pumped up your critical thinking
shuts down so when your critical
thinking shuts down you're not able to
question what the hell am i doing right
you're just going along with the crowd
and this kind of you know mass hysteria
sets in where everybody's chanting the
same thing sort of reaffirms your
loyalty
we know from our studies of cults that
one thing that they are are closed
systems i call them self-sealing systems
the sort of clever but also dangerous
aspect of of the online communities is
the way the algorithms work and so that
you click on something and before you
know it you something else pops up and
then you click on that and you get led
down these paths without maybe even
realizing where you're going and without
having time to think about it there is a
risk in in banning these groups from the
more public social media which has
happened with some of the groups and
then they go to the more secretive
social media platforms it's like falling
down the rabbit hole before you know it
you're like lost in a world of
like-minded thinkers and
think you've found a community that you
feel part of and
you're gone to the people who knew you
before
the charismatic leader is someone who
has power over you it's a social
relationship and it's based on this
imbalance of power and it's actually not
an attribute that someone is born with
but it's the fact that you attribute
that quality to that person and that's
what gives them the power and then you
are obligated to honor and revere and
worship that person and the charismatic
leader is obligated to be that
charismatic leader and do things that
makes him or her seem special
so who would fill that role in online
communities we don't necessarily see one
leader standing up to be the
charismatic leader but there may be
different people who play that role at
different times when q was at its peak
and
he was sending out messages and i think
people did actually
see him as a mystical
charismatic messianic leader he had that
kind of sway and power over people q
also was
similar to the cult leaders who say they
have the direct line to god q presented
himself also as someone who was really
an insider and knew exactly what was
going on and that he was going to tell
us and warn us about the deep state and
things that were happening in the
government that were harming the
american public just about everybody i
know
has somebody in their family or in their
social network who has been lost to them
with political divisions in america at
an all-time high
what advice does dr lolich have for
someone trying to reconnect with a loved
one in an online group that feels
cult-like another parallel to what we
see in cults is this concept of
cognitive dissonance which means
when reality butts up against your
belief system 99 of the time people are
going to stick with their belief system
rather than go with reality because it
what it's what they know it's what their
identity is wrapped up in and it's safer
everybody who's in one of these closed
groups has doubts and they're never able
to express those doubts we need to be
compassionate to that person but i call
it critical compassion because it's
something you need to do very carefully
so first you want to build rapport you
want to bring back good memories of
things you did before don't challenge
the person don't think oh i've got the
best argument it's only going to drive
that person deeper into
whatever it is they believe in so you
have to think about how to connect with
that person again in a way
that is going to just open up their eyes
a little bit it may happen six months
down the road and that's why i say never
give up never give up hope don't ever
cut that person off being in a cult or
being in one of these hateful groups
there's a lot of loneliness and stress
if that person can see a way out they'll
take it one day and they'll thank you